i think joe rogan though like like you
said like
the whole podcasting world is just
another stratosphere for comedians now
yeah and what he does for like it's like
joe rogan what he does for you know
everybody like he allows because he is
the king of the influence right now he's
like he's the stern of podcasting it's
he does kind of allow everybody to kind
of say what they want like he can be the
punchline like stern even sometimes to
be a punchline you know just because
they're kings of the media in that sense
but
now everything's open everybody so we
can go do everything because this guy's
like no no we got to keep freedom of
speech you know i mean like we have to
be able to say these harsh words and say
these harsh things that way we can get
to the good [ __ ] you know but maintain
the freedom that way they start taking
away [ __ ] then they'll just start
picking us what they want to take away
and that's that you know that
the woke mob or whatever the [ __ ] it is
but it's like that getting rid of speech
thing or you can't joke about that like
when people came at michael che about
simone bilas it was like
okay like he retweeted some [ __ ] that
was that was awful
but i'm glad we're talking about it
right and that's kind of the end of the
day it's like we're talking about hard
[ __ ] but i'm glad we're talking about it